all right let's try doing this today we
are flogging not with their usual camera
we are vlogging with my new iPhone
we just bought new iPhones in the last
vlog I'm gonna test out how well the
iPhone does with vlogging all right so
we're at Target right now and we're
trying to look for a present a gift for
this white elephant thing there's gonna
be a JK party tonight at the office
Christmas themed and I got my little bit
of green on I exist got his uh this is
like May for Christmas it looks like it
and you got your read on buy our
Christmas bun really
[Music]
that one looks expensive and then we
have we have a budget between thirty and
forty dollars for this white elephant
yeah I pick up white I love thinkest I
try to think of something I would want
so I don't know white noise machines
canticle that's pretty good one
it's where you take a present and then
other people take presents and then you
end up swapping presents and then you
can ever know what you're gonna get yeah
I like how you're skipping Isaac Isaac's
in the holiday mood
[Music]
good tonight
I like the black the black pants tight
yummy
[Music]
it's a pleasure to play that
exaggerating like he's so dramatic I
think it's to come to the office every
day after school before he started his
after-school program and so now he's
been in his after-school program so he
never gets to come to JK cuz he doesn't
get out until 6:00 by the time you get
out like all the meetings are over we're
already at home so go enjoy the office
go check out all the new stuff it's very
Christmasy here today beep dramatic did
you hear about what is it hi mommy he's
an adult you'll bring adult now thank
you
he looks Asian today does it yes he does
[Music]
oh you're bringing that way how about
you guys okay all right
[Music]
Oh God
[Music]
[Applause]
hire anyone by 1557 mine but of course
everyone's a loose everyone's a winner I
was a loser not everyone's a winner
we're about to do white outfit
[Music]
are you ready to get a surprise you're
ready to upgrade or downgrade I think
it's just for the fun of it it's not
really like oh what am I gonna get it's
just like oh this fun world-changing
true
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's interested you better steal that I
know you better get as a selection
system and everything you want a cheap
one cheap date ideas I don't want a
cheap date McDonald
[Applause]
McDonald all right there might be
something amazing in there or you have a
chance to steal this but there might be
something amazing in there but if you
feel if you steal this right now that
this is yours for good no you stole this
after he's doing you don't want it I
know
[Applause]
I got that that's the one I kind of look
going forward make up what is that or
first idiots fragrance sets
I guess hi
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
clean them hey guys check out my outfit
what do you think is it 90s enough today
we are going to Cassie's 90s Christmas
parties of Cassie aka Blogilates she's
having a 90s theme party today and so
this is my 90s that I got going on I
don't know I tried doing that top knot I
even tried to keep combing my eyebrows
to view thinner and like to do more like
the 90s style and then I got like the
choker or the hoops I don't know and I
got something like flannel around my
waist I'm missing the shoes but I'm
gonna have some like high-heeled kind of
boot so we're trying to look at Leo
coming Leo DiCaprio my hair's not long
enough to do it I realize how long the
nineties hair was like it's really full
back then and nowadays thin it out and
it's just not the same I tried doing the
whole bang stuff and this is not long
enough they actually be in my face so
we're trying it in the face they can't
do it however you look good though
look look at the baggy pants we went up
to the thrift store to buy some pants oh
and your shoes yeah these are like my
actual shoes a lot of this stuff was
actually stuff that I used to wear like
a long time ago so I guess I'm going for
the more subtle approach than 90s you
know there's like two ways to go about a
costume party super loud every single
stereotype yeah and then there's like
what 90s people actually tried to dress
like and I guess I tried doing that yeah
same same with me I mean I already owned
this dress I already owned this flannel
and this choker and the tight actually
everything that I'm wearing I've already
are you buying it I didn't buy a single
thing yes Isaac just got picked up so
he's away for the weekend like always
and uh yeah so we're gonna head out now
okay how I get I this is fine look cute
I think hey my screaming oh my god looks
like on you know yeah oh you've hidden
sprayed my perfume I don't know what
year this perfume came out and but I got
curb do you guys remember curb I can't
believe I still have my bottle look how
much I have left don't know why yeah I
remember buying this like and
thousand three or something like been a
long time I don't know do perfumes
expire I've had my perfume a long time
yes this is what we got going on for our
nineties outfits but we did also want to
mention though thank you guys so much
for all the suggestions on where we
should go for a pregnancy bucket list we
love to do them all we're gonna make a
decision soon and book those tickets and
then we'll let you guys know where we
decided to go but thank you for all
those suggestions we really appreciate
it
but yeah so now we're heading off we'll
see you guys at Kathy's party
[Music]
[Music]
Casey year one to a 90's party
[Music]
alright guys so we've done a blog much
at Cassie's party but we ended up going
out to a club with Phil and his
girlfriend Helen the club just closed we
are both a little drunk because they
made a six-shot and so I think we're the
plan is we're gonna go have some dinner
so we never ever ever go out we were
home buddies even though Isaac always
spends the weekends at his dad's house
we never actually take advantage and
really try to like go out like in our
early twenties it's pretty cool hanging
out with Bill and his girlfriend Helen
because then they actually brought us
out to a club slash bar or whatever the
whole time were here
like I felt so insecure by myself
because we're wearing 90's clothes yeah
we're still in her nineties it's not as
bad as Phil though because Phil was
wearing a sailor moon shirt with like a
part down straight the middle of his
head
[Music]